the critical First 48 Hours has come and
gone and hope is turning into grief
the cries crack through the crowd
bringing home a painful new reality
[Music]
in these kind of outbursts happen every
once in a while people just collapse
from sheer grief from from just the
weight of the devastation
she's just she's just inconsolable she's
got everyone around her but
it doesn't help
there's a growing awareness that it's
simply too late
[Music]
people are getting
pace of rescue
this resident has been watching for the
last two days you're taking too long he
says let us dig ourselves
foreign
this building was also home to a man and
his wife from Aleppo Syria who are still
missing
tep has been a place of Refuge for
hundreds of thousands of syrians fleeing
the war now displaced again
Khalid left Aleppo 10 years ago at the
start of the war
he says the last few days have reminded
him of life in war-torned Syria and the
suffering felt by families still there
but those in Syria have been devastated
by the earthquake too with little access
to Aid isolated rebel-held areas a
sanctioned government and damaged roads
are limiting the pathways for relief
it is a huge shortage in medication
medical consumables shelter food NFI
kids with no International
aid until now unfortunately
syrians feel they are they are forgotten
actually we
and not more than one week we will run
out of this stocks as you know this is a
big disaster and it needs International
health
back in gazian tap Syrian refugees have
spent a decade making themselves at home
to now live in cars
war is nothing this lady says this is a
war with God
uprooted uncertain and unable to turn
anywhere else
but back to that same God praying for
Mercy once again
Sky News